[Music]
actions
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry
whatever
[Music]
[Music]
it is weird staring at you for that long
whoa
let's save me mj
okay
you've been rolling this
[Laughter]
[Music]
just me
here buddy let me help you yes
it's okay should we do the kiss
[Music]
his great power
comes great responsibility
keep being a friendly neighborhood
spider-man
that's what we do yeah it's what we do
all right let's do this
focus trust your tingle
i have the tingle thing just not for
brent
you are amazing thank you will you say
it no i kind of needed to hear that
thank you
peter one
eight or two
you know three
i love you guys
we just had a little dance in the suit
yeah cuddle we had a cuddle the cobwebs
off a little bit for me
doing a photo shoot with
two lads in lycra
[Music]
[Music]
the suit can definitely be like a
challenge at times when you got to get
in the full thing um
but then like getting comfortable in it
there is something fun yeah it just
helps as an actor when you get in your
costume you begin to like feel it more
and embody it more and i'm still
processing it's all happening still i'm
catching up yeah this only just happened
but objectively you got pretty free
pretty quick oh yeah
that's true you started to feel pretty
at home yeah
pretty quickly i did yeah i just
have no explanation for it it just did
instinctual yeah it releases something
it just did it
uh i think i can repair dylan and marco
but the others
the idea that they are all the same
thing and they could all come together
they sort of help each other that to me
felt like it was part of dna of the
story that we were already trying to
tell and that gave me an entry point to
actually get them together so that it
was a story element and an emotional
thing
you're okay
i gotta go yeah yeah i got it you okay
they grow and they change and they
evolve from different writers different
artists in the case of the films
different actors that's why the marvel
characters have persevered so long
through decades
and then you have the fun of starting to
pitch it to the actors and doing
something that is worthy of their time
and of their energy and stepping back
into this role
i had butterflies in those meetings with
kobe and andy hoping that they would
sign up this is peter parker's peter
parker spider-man spider-man there are
other me's from another dimension this
is the wizard that i was telling you
about
watching tom through this journey from
the first movie into now has been so
rewarding the first movie is about
spider-man really wanting to prove
himself to tony stark and working so
hard to do that that he ends up screwing
up and making things a million times
worse like that's just exactly how i
felt on the first movie tom and i both
felt the same like where are we what's
going on this is a crazy opportunity
let's not screw it up this is insane
look at this thing look we both grew up
together i don't feel like it was a
parental role i felt like we were all
the kids what's interesting in the
previous films is that he really has
been the spider boy what about me what
about you
what if mrs dark needs me or something
or i don't know something that goes down
and this film is about him becoming
spider-man it's about him growing up
making his own decisions and stepping up
to the plate as a full-blown avenger and
it's been really nice to kind of have
that dovetail between myself and
spider-man homecoming and now who i am
and who peter parker is in spider-man
their way home my name is peter parker
and i
would like a coffee
please
[Music]
we're going to lift you up on a cherry
picker and you're going to jump off
how they became super villains it's just
so funny i fell into a super collider
gotta be careful where you fall
to work with them is honestly the
highlight of my career me and toby
arrived and all of their arms were just
open
[Music]
[Music]
red butterflies with toby and andrew
hoping they would sign up
[Music]
you